in our copywriting uh program we say be
clear not clever
clear not clever it's really hard to be
crystal clear it's super easy to create
marketees and be clever but in the grand
scheme we believe clarity wins
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right
so remy have you
you can be honest have you ever listened
to the podcast
i've heard your clips and i love them
all right good answer you know what
you're getting into
yeah you know what you're getting into
and you're also we'll just say it you're
you're one of the reasons you're here is
because i like you we're friends another
reason is you're smart and good at this
stuff but the third reason is you just
had a podcast come out and you'd be
talking about doing a podcast forever
now you actually have one it's about um
are they the people are anonymous right
there it's anonymous couples having
discussions about money well most of
them use their real names and they're
all real voices so
i always wanted to
uh listen in on couples fighting about
money discussing money but you can never
do it you know the only place you've
ever heard anyone fight about money is
on a movie and now you actually get to
listen to real couples sharing real
numbers
talking about what's going on with their
money how do they disagree and then what
do i help them do to get over it
and what's it called
it's called i will teach you to be rich
with ramit sethi and so this is a little
bit like uh what's her name esther perel
is this sort of like her model where uh
i forgot what her podcast is called it's
very good she's like kind of like a
relationship coach and she has a couple
coming in she's a therapist
yeah esther perel is amazing you know
she helps couples with therapy mine is
not therapy but if you imagine for
example a couple where
the classic example is you know he's an
overspender
we don't have enough money for that
that's a classic one but then it becomes
much more interesting for example we
have a couple
the guy
hates hates
paying too much for organic blueberries
he hates it so when he orders
blueberries he has two tabs open he's
comparing notes i know all your personal
finance nerds listening to this are like
what's the problem that's totally normal
no it's not normal he opens it up he's
comparing cross compartment
guess his net worth
what do you guys think
i'm guessing it's high based on the
setup so uh i don't know we'll go over i
would say over over 10 million
sam
uh a million bucks
eight million dollars and he's comparing
the price of blueberries
and really what this shows is
money is not just about math in fact we
overvalue math and we undervalue
psychology which is what the podcast
gets into
did did launch go well how how how the
the the first episodes do
great i mean we're learning right so i
know all the metrics cold for email and
even social stuff but for podcasts we're
like i texted some of my friends hey
what's good and they told me some
numbers are like okay so we released it
now so it's getting tens of thousands of
downloads per episode we're happy about
that i'm more happy that people are
writing in and they go
my wife and i finally talked about money
for the first time we've been married
for six years
i'm like
yes so the quantitative stuff seems to
be good but i'm more interested for a
creative project like this in the
qualitative
growing our podcast we've talked about
it a bit on this podcast which people
like and sometimes don't like us talking
about it too much but it's been the
hardest thing that i've had to grow
what you'll learn i'm sure you've
already learned this is that so with
email you can advertise somewhere or you
can write a blog post and you know
exactly where the new email subscriber
is coming from um and you know you can
guess how long they're gonna stay with
you with podcasts you don't really know
that so like it's like itunes won't tell
you how many subscribers you have
they're not exactly going to tell you
where they come from uh you don't you
don't know a lot of information and so
it's really really challenging and so
when we grow we'll do a bunch of stuff
and we're like did it work and it takes
us a week and we're like well the
numbers went up let's just continue
doing everything we just did did it not
work no it didn't work all right so
let's just change it's been it's been
really hard uh
anyway but so you uh all right so ramit
you have this your main thing is i will
teach you to be rich and it started as a
blog uh it's a book now and it's this
major course business and that's
actually what i wanted to talk about a
little bit early on was course
businesses sean just launched a course
called power writing it's called power
writing all right yeah
wait you don't even know the name of
your own partner's new course what's
wrong with you well i knew it was called
power writing i didn't know if it was
like power writing and then like you
know dash the how to write like i don't
know what the [__] hold on hold on
i'm taking over this podcast right now
sean are you offended that number one he
didn't know the name of your course and
number two that he hasn't bought it for
full price not at all no uh sam
basically taught me everything that i
teach in the course so in a way i
actually owe him some royalties really
and then the second thing is
uh when he asked that i just thought
it's like a setup you know like you know
when you kind of give someone an assist
you're like oh you wrote a book right
what's what's the name of that book
you're just letting them plug their
thing and it's like that's a podcast old
trick
okay that didn't go the way i wanted so
oh look it did look it's called i know
what it's called it's called power
writing but there's a sub headline as
well right sean no there's no sub
headline and also
also i think i'm you guys are retiring i
taught it just this time and it was like
it was really good and i'm like
unfortunately i'm the type that gets
bored of things really quickly so just
when we got it where like after the the
second one from the first one the second
one made double the money and it took a
quarter of the time which is like
exactly what you would want and it
should the answer should be go do it
again and instead i don't want to do it
at all i'm just like okay i want to move
on to something else
you written can you say you said the
first time how much it did so can you
say this time how much i did the second
time uh just double that so for those
who are following along just double the
number that's how much you made this
time
really okay and you're not gonna do this
again you're done i'm gonna teach
something else something else i'm
interested in something that's like
totally different like which will be
like kicking over the sand castle and
starting over which is kind of silly
from a business point of view but from
uh
enjoying myself and entertaining myself
point of view it's the right move
but your courses are different than
remedies so remy i i bought your
copywriting one um again i'm sorry i
don't remember the name of it just it
was just called matt
it was sale up on sales pages what would
which one did i buy
uh we have our our biggest one is called
call to action we have another one
called behind the sales page where you
actually watch me write a sales page
that i think made millions and millions
of dollars so it's maybe one of those
okay i took it i took it two years ago
i've taken a couple of yours but your
business is different than sean sean's
was the cohort one have you ever have
you done one of these cohort classes
yeah i've done several in fact i'm doing
one as we speak right now uh cohort
classes are definitely hot
um it's fun to watch this new model if
you trace
the history of courses i mean they've
been going on for generations but let's
just say in the last 20 years um
you know first off was e-books and this
is they were kind of hot in the early
2000s um you had dating ebooks you had a
famous ebook on how to train your parrot
those were typically between 10 and
about 100 bucks
um then you started seeing video being
added
video added higher pricing um
and it was technically very difficult
because they didn't youtube wasn't even
out uh when somebody started
then it went on to higher value
people got more sophisticated with
topics you added masterminds which were
hot and they've kind of fizzled out over
the last few years now you have cohort
based courses and there's some focus on
completion rates which we can talk about
that's a terrible decision to do if you
choose to do that we can talk about that
but yeah cohorts are hot doesn't
necessarily mean they're lasting but
they're certainly hot right now
so how many courses right now do you
guys have
um we have between 20 and 25 live
is your business doing north of 20
million in sales
i'm not going to share my sales numbers
um i thought you might not i thought you
might not but i respect that you just
you just told me that because if i ask
someone and they're like oh you know i'm
like just say you don't want to talk
about it that's totally exciting
yeah yeah we have a private business we
have a great team and 20 to 25 programs
and
over 50 000 customs around 50 000
customers so we're thrilled with that
you're not teaching these live then
recorded
generally they're recorded the biggest
ones are we do do some live ones to
experiment with concepts
and it's just fun well you know like you
mentioned sean you like to be able to
engage and then you're like okay do we
want to double down on that or are we
done with that and what do you think uh
so
so i think some people are interested in
your course business but i think more
people would be interested in
what you've learned about the course
business having done a bunch of it being
kind of like near the top of the game
there which is like first and foremost
who's crushing it when it comes to
courses what's a model you look at where
you say just from a pure like
respect of the way that that business
works i respect this course business
what stands out to you might be your own
great great question because
crushing it and who i respect are
totally different
let me break that down who i respect i
respect um people like marie forleo who
has a awesome business she's runs it her
way she launches when she wants to which
is sparingly um it's beautifully done
and she she just loves the way
she runs her business that's awesome um
i also respect people like
like some of the
the legacy people in our industry jay
abraham who i just saw for coffee two
days ago uh he's one of my mentors and
he's been around since the 80s in fact
even before brian dean high integrity uh
matthew hussey in the dating space he's
great he's a friend of mine
um and then i think reforge is
interesting although i think that that
is quite different because it's venture
backed than what the typical individual
wants to create so what i admire about
all those folks
high integrity and we can talk about why
integrity is lacking in the course
business because it is
uh they run the business the way they
want to each of those could easily
double their revenue easily if they did
a couple of different decisions they
don't
uh and
and and that's why i respect it
john do you know who jay abraham is no
okay so he's
i'm gonna guess probably in his 60s and
he wears a he looks like if i like told
you like imagine what like a in the 60s
or in the 60s what a rich british guy
would dress like if he were like into
hunting like in the countryside of
england that's what this guy dresses up
like
impeccable you know the hunter and
jumanji that's what i just that's what i
got in my head
that's a really good yes okay so google
it he wears like a kind of like a scarf
tucked into a tie and like you would
imagine him smoking like a pipe right
for me am i wrong like he like dresses
like in fact let me add to that i once
asked him jay because we're close and
you know he's been a mentor for many
years
he tells me you know i flew to asia and
you know i said jay what'd you wear
while you're on stage because he loves
he's a sartorial he's into it
he goes well you know how many suits i
take for a three-day presentation right
i go
one he goes 40.
i said what
and he said
they're hiring me not just for the
information i'm gonna teach
they're hiring me to be theatrical it's
a show and so at every break he changes
his suit now to the typical silicon
valley utilitarian they're like not so
stupid what's the metrics there's more
to life than metrics you silicon valley
nerds that's a huge mistake that all
these roi attribution positive
sometimes in fact the best companies
know that's why they advertise in times
square they can't track that but they do
it because it's the right thing to do
and it's about brandon jay's a genius at
doing that that's why he's been at the
top of the game for decades and he's
been at the time he's been he's been
around forever and if you go and study
like a bunch of copywriting books i
think was that his background was he a
copywriter
yeah one of the best
okay so he's a copywriter and when i
don't know him i've i've seen him in
person once or twice i know you know him
well but this guy has got this huge
cloud of mystery around him to me from
the outside and and i think that's the
vibe he purposely gives so like for all
i know he could be a billionaire i have
no idea like what this guy's story is
he's just this like business like guri
type of guy what what is his story
what's the truth about him
so the the truth is that he he was doing
highly innovative marketing
for the last 40 years he would go into
companies like gold companies um
umbrella companies all kinds of random
industries dozens and dozens of
industries and he would show them ways
to exponentially grow their
their sales icy hop was one of his and
he has a fantastic story he bought
remnant radio advertising he paid a
hundred percent of the first fee to the
radio station so it was no risk to them
and then he took the long-term profits
and grew that business in a massive way
so i'll tell you what i like about him i
like that his ideas are extremely
powerful in fact on my bookshelf i have
a very highly curated bookshelf of some
of the best marketing books that i've
ever read i have two of his that are on
that bookshelf um he he takes a
multi-dimensional approach to business
so for example he would tell me early on
ramit
put your customers at the center of your
world i said okay what does that mean
and he's got this thing called the
theory of preeminence he would say look
tell them explicitly
tell them
you are here you might not be ready to
buy today that's fine enjoy my free
material to use it for as long as you
want when you are ready i will be here
and i will be here for the rest of your
life which is totally true and you know
i do some things in my business that are
very unconventional for example i don't
allow people with credit card debt to
join our flagship programs the higher
end ones that costs us millions of
dollars every year and it's funny people
will plagiarize our sales pages they'll
plagiarize our email copy for some
reason they don't plagiarize that policy
i wonder why that is because 90 of their
customers would disappear overnight but
when we do that even though it costs us
in the short term it benefits us
tremendously in the long term so jay
helped us really articulate that vision
clearly
what does he sell
what you you're talking about course
businesses that you like what what's his
course he doesn't care he doesn't care
about that anymore he's been doing that
for general for decades he does uh
rare consulting for equity arrangements
you can find most of his stuff free on
his website if you sign up for it but
he's not doing that anymore he's done it
he's shared a ton of his insight now he
wants to work with selective clients
did he tell you any good stories about
uh icy hot or one of the brands that he
helped
i see hot was one of one of my favorites
it's in this book and he's told me all
about it he told me about gold and how
he
um helped this gold business that was
sort of struggling and they repositioned
the way they sold gold and it exploded
their business he's got tons of great
stories in his book my favorite one it
has a terrible title but it's a great
book
getting everything you can out of all
you've got is really good one page in
that book helped me build a
multi-million dollar product i was
sitting on a wednesday wednesday i have
strategy days and i just read and i
think and i read one of his pages and i
it all clicked for me and i launched a
multi-million dollar program of ours uh
called ramit's brain trust and it was
all because of that book so speaking of
uh speaking of terrible titles uh
we have a podcast title that is
both kind of catchy but also kind of
cringey
i would say you also have a title that
is kind of catchy and kind of cringey
so
we've talked about kind of our feelings
on it give us your take on
both your name as as well as
doing names like this so give us the
kind of like what's your what's your
mindset is it all pros are there no cons
are there a mix how do you think about
it
now there's a lot of cons i'll tell you
i'll tell you the the blunt truth so i
created i will teach you to be rich
while i was a student at stanford and i
was helping my friends in the dining
halls with their personal finance and i
had learned and i built my own system
because i took some of my scholarship
money and put in the stock market
and
uh here i am trying to help my friends
and they were like oh that sounds
awesome because i got an overdraft fee
and they would never show up to my free
classes so i was like okay i gotta name
this
to make it more catchy and then event
and that didn't work
so eventually i started the blog
looking back
i want to first say i was sober when i
picked the name okay so
and it was catchy
but i will say um it's come with its
downsides for example you know i've been
sitting on panels there's like the ceo
of a fortune 500 company another ceo or
senior vp and then there's ramit sethi
ceo of i will teach you to be rich and
the first reaction at some of these
places is not good okay
but
even though many of my really smart
friends including some venture
capitalists and others they were like
you got to change your name you got to
change your name
early on i was like you might be right
and then i started going well there's
some costs i've already invested all
this time
and then it just became too difficult
and so i finally have really owned it um
i will say that
i know very well when people hear this
name of this book or the site they go
that sounds like a scam so the
conversations are
seriously it's not what it sounds like
check it out
and then
i kind of have come to love that i love
the push pull they go it sounds like a
scam they come here it's hyper tactical
it has the exact accounts to use they go
oh this sounds like every other money
person wait a minute this guy graduated
from stanford oh wow he's in the you
know times square new york times
bestseller so i love that push-pull i
don't mind a little skepticism because i
trust our material is so good that if
they are ready they will receive it
and if you were going to rebrand had you
ever come up with a backup what would
you go to
yeah we we've played around with some
ideas i do think there's room in our
future business
for an extension
for different names
but but with all that said you know what
i love
clear names some of our best programs
are find your dream job we've helped
people get 50 000 raises that's like
right on the money earn 1k
help you earn 1k on the side and for
many people turns into earn 100k on the
side so i do love clear names and in our
copywriting
program we say be clear not clever
clear not clever it's really hard to be
crystal clear it's super easy to create
marketees and be clever but in the grand
scheme we believe clarity wins
and you've been doing this since what
like oh nine or something when it when i
started this site in four oh four and
do you think that this could last
another so you're at it that's what 10
11 12 uh
16 years 17 years can it last like
what's it gonna what what would a brand
like this a course business and your
brand what would it look like in 20 or
30 years and are you going to continue
doing it for that long you think oh yeah
i mean i love what i do so first of all
it's not a course business sorry we just
happen to have courses
but we also have a paul then a blog a
brand
so it's it's an education business
um we have a book with over a million
copies sold right you could just as well
say it's a book business because we sell
more books we sell courses
um
but
i don't love the concept of quote a
course business
um you will find that many of the
successful course creators they go wait
a minute there's lots of different ways
to reach people i'm going to do events
i'm going to do a podcast so courses
simply become a nice which which part of
the
empire so right so i'm pretty fascinated
i've been studying this kind of what i
call solopreneurs basically people who
try to build like a personal monopoly
around some domain
whether it's a guy who there's a guy
who's like i'm the best dog trainer i
will just teach you everything you don't
know about training your dog i'm just
like i train dogs for the stars but then
i'm going to give you the information
for free over here i love that i think
these are there is an infinite number of
these like personal monopolies that you
could create even within one right so
let's say your personal finance there's
personal finance for guys who want to be
billionaires there's people who want to
be lean fire there's people who want to
um do it where it's like you know you're
only gonna you're you're gonna maximize
your time right so it's like the kind of
four hour work week style there's
there's a number of these personal
monopolies and i've been interested to
look under the hood of these and see two
things one is
what's uh what does that business really
look like because you only see ramit
sethi you write you don't know like how
many people you got on your team
yeah we have about 20 20 to 25 at a
given right so like even though it looks
like an individual brand obviously
there's a there's a full talented team
of people helping out help me make it
happen and then you have like
many different plates that you're
spinning at once you've got the blog
plate you've got the podcast plate
you've got the books plate the courses
plate there's gonna be you know there's
probably four more that i mean job board
who knows what else you got um which
plate is the
so i would say the usually what i found
and you tell me if it's true for you i
found that there's the audience core one
which might be like the blog like the
blog is our core thing for growing the
audience the free audience and then
there's like and then there's this other
thing which is monetizes kind of like
the one to five percent of the audience
the best and this is what this is where
the money comes in to pay for these 25
people that work at my company so what
is it for you is it a newsletter or a
blog what's the main thing on the
audience side and what's the main thing
on the business side is it courses
that's a great question i think in
general your model is correct i think
that there are places that are better
for audiences and typically this will be
things like social media it's easier to
grow that than to grow the number of
customers that's just sort of a given of
the internet
for us
audience wise i think um
social media for us for sure so we have
people on twitter instagram
to some extent youtube and now the
podcast i think that will end up being a
pretty substantial part of the business
audience-wise um the program those are
all about each generation
that's like the leader
well uh instagram is the best
it's the best be in my twitter um
because i am
i love it it's like i'll get up and i'll
start instagramming and tweeting and
stuff and now we've got a little iwt
support in there so we've got you know a
regular posting schedule those are great
and actually we've learned how to
monetize things like instagram um you
know instagram is a nice part of our
business as well you also reply to
trolls on twitter which is awesome and
instagram
i reply to all trolls yeah i love it i'm
waiting in my life for one smart troll
you know i have i've helped over 10
million people i have uh over a million
books sold 50 000 customers our team is
amazing i'm still praying one day can
there be an intelligent troll out there
it's so far no it's um it's very
difficult you know i get anti-vaxxers
who write me you know i tell them
you know you have trouble deciphering a
menu at olive garden and you're over
here giving me medical advice i don't
think so so you know these guys they
they're and they're all guys they uh
they really feel that they need some
meaning in life
and i'm happy to give it to them and
show others how to respond to trolls why
do you why why do you spend the
interview there by the way
isn't that a big energy suck why because
it's fun for a while it is fun to slap
down trolls for a bit but it i've for me
it gets exhausting but you seem to
thrive on it you seem like even right
now i can see a little pep in your step
just thinking about it well
i remember listening to a navy seal who
said when others do push-ups they get
tired when i do push-ups i get strong
and i found the same because dealing
with trolls keeps me sharp um and i'll
tell you why it's not just you know for
kicks and to make fun of them it's that
in my life
you know i'm hanging out with guys like
you
smart guys who are dissecting business
models and and healthy whatever
i don't get the chance to talk to
someone who comes up to me and says you
know
vaccines are fake
or
um these sort of crackpot you're you're
only doing this so you can make money
if i wanted to be rich i would create a
book on being rich you know i've
candidly never had somebody come up to
me in real life and say that and in part
that's because when people come up in
real life they're actually very positive
pleasant they usually have very nice
things to say
what typically happens with these trolls
now i've um had conversations with
thousands of them and i save and cross
um catalog all these conversations so
it's fascinating right over time you can
build a corpus of what's going on
remember i studied psychology at
technology and psychology at stanford so
i'm fascinated with human behavior so i
want to know what's going on in your
life that you would reach out out of
nowhere to somebody who doesn't know you
and go
[__] you
so when they say that to me i go hey
what's going on man you having a bad
hair day and we start talking and so now
i have metrics 50 of them will never
reply
of those who reply 50
will go oh oh my god i didn't know
anyone would actually read this oh i'm
sorry hey man big fan which kind of
leads to the question if you didn't know
anyone's going to reply why on earth
would you send that that's kind of sad
and then the remaining 50 which is 25 of
the original
they will kind of double down and that
actually is a very interesting
conversation to have like what's going
on with someone that they would say that
and so i don't always get to a
resolution but it hones my
conversational skills and i get to
understand and peek into the psyche of
someone like that
i love that you have the like
intellectual answer when it's probably
just really fun to just clap back at
people
no no explanation we've all felt it um
so uh sam i think you were gonna ask
something before i jumped in on the
troll thing
well i i i'm still curious about the
course business and and i'll tell you
why i'm curious about it i'm curious
about it
because like i bet you you've been in
this since 2004. there's i i have a
bunch of friends neville noah you who
are just i think you're maybe i think
you're maybe eight years older than me
um
who are old enough older than me and
that they've seen like the beginning of
like the web 1.0 course businesses and
there are some people that just crushed
it so we talked about ebbing ebb and
pagan uh what was his name david
d'angelo was his uh what's his name and
that stuff i love hearing stories about
that it's so fascinating about all these
guys just killing it on the internet and
it's just fascinating it's like learning
about like a drug cartel or something
like it's just like intrinsically
exciting to hear about like these like
it's like cowboy feeling type of
business and also on here you mentioned
the company agora and you're saying that
i asked you can one can some of these
course businesses reach 100 million in
revenue and you said
you sometimes they can but it's
incredibly hard but the ones who do
they're really just uh they're like huge
newsletters that sell courses so yeah
that's what i wanted to ask you
okay so let me take you back and i'm
gonna share a couple stories from the
history because we have um
created over
30 programs
and we have served you know tons and
tons of people so
um a few things i've learned first of
all i remember our first major course we
launched was called earn 1k and the
reason we created it was that i went on
book tour and i went around to 13
different cities and i was like hey what
should i create this is way back in the
day uh 2009
in the depths of the recession
and they go love your stuff on finances
and automation but i really want to know
how to make more money okay that was
fairly unusual back at that time so came
home and we identified all these
different uh areas of making money we
created a program on freelancing because
we know it and we could teach it we
recorded that in the back of the
automatic office so we got hooked up
with matt he was like okay you can
record it in the back we didn't have any
fancy camera equipment
but the content was good and we launched
it and it was
497 dollars at the time
and the thing converted
way better than we thought it converted
too well it was around two percent if i
recall correctly
and
i told people in the last email i was
like guys this is actually converting
way better than i thought i'm going to
raise the price and a lot of people were
like haha marketing gimmick haha that's
so crazy and then at the end it made 600
000 on our first launch
and we raised the price and never
lowered it again ever so it was
hilarious because a couple weeks later
people like hey can i get in at the
original price we're like no
and so that was the first thing where we
realized oh my gosh
packaging matters
topic matters conversion rate and
pricing are profoundly meaningful in
your business so that taught us a lot
moving along you know we had other
programs we launched another business
program i think it did like
five million or six million in one week
and we wrote about that on the tim
ferriss blog um you can see kind of the
entire flow of how we did that that's a
great one by the way i i've when we
launched trends i read that and reread
it a ton of times i think it's like uh a
five million dollar launch or something
yeah is that yeah i figured yeah we took
people behind the scenes because there's
a you have to understand it's like
think of all the movement behind
launching a movie
okay we're not doing a movie but we're
doing a launch we write an entire book
per launch and much of that gets
discarded and we still end up with a
book that's how much we write and create
so we wanted to show people what goes
into it because it's not just luck at
certain levels it's very strategic and
there's an element of luck too
but then moving you know moving along
you see a lot of other models that came
and went for a question like can you
make it to 100 million bucks
you can
but a couple things change
one you become an acquisition machine
you cannot make it to 100 million
dollars without a true massive
acquisition machine and that means that
most of your business will be focused on
acquisition and in the self-development
world or money world if that's what you
choose to pursue
if you want to play that game you have
to become very very
uh mercenary so for example you will see
facebook ads they're basically like
uh make a million bucks in a week i'm
being hyperbolic but you get it why
it's that that is what people respond to
when you are doing a true acquisition
machine
if you want to build a boutique business
with high integrity that is antithetical
to that so it's very important to know
for example in software you're you don't
necessarily have to build a very
hyperbolic business right look at
hubspot they're not over there saying
fix all your crm in 10 hours that's not
what they're saying at all
but in self-development or in the course
business it becomes more and more
aggressive the bigger and bigger you
want to get
and that's kind of like one of the one
of the downsides of the business which
is
it's kind of like you know the hustle we
we had a conference hustle con and a
bunch of other conferences and it kind
of sucked when that was our main stream
of revenue because the more money it
made the more people we had and the more
people it had the worse it got
and
that that sucked i hated that i hated
that i hated that i hated that and that
was a huge challenge for us well it
didn't end up being a challenge because
we were like all right it just can't be
the main revenue driver but yeah well
let's do a quick switch i want to do um
some of your uh both business ideas
because this is a idea podcast and
secondly i want to ask you about some
money hacks but let's start with ideas
so what we like to ask everybody is cool
it's it's always fascinating to figure
out how do you do what you do how long
you've been doing it great like that's
kind of pass facing
but what i found is that anybody who's
talented enough to build their own
business like you have and is out there
operating in the field they see tons of
other opportunities that you just you
have more ideas than you have time to go
do them and so or maybe you're not the
right person to go do that idea but you
think somebody should somebody who loves
so and so should go do that
um
what are some ideas business ideas that
you've seen that you you think are
genuinely interesting or worth we're
chatting about and then we can toss them
out to the audience
okay i always focus on
where's the demand where is their
insatiable demand you know as we talk
about in our earnable program go where
the fish are
and um
the first one i would create would be a
business around pets
okay first of all i don't have pets and
i don't want pets my wife is constantly
telling me let's get a dog i'm like
we're never getting a dog ever
and i want to tell you why
because when i was a kid my sisters
wanted a dog
and we couldn't because my dad was
allergic sixteen years later we found
out he wasn't allergic
i love it to this day i love that my dad
just point blank just lied to us for
almost 20 years i said god bless dad and
so now i will do the same thing
um
if my wife is listening i'm allergic as
well it's tragic it's genetic
so um but but um for the people who have
pets
it's hilarious
they will literally spend anything so
one of my good friends she said oh yeah
like you know i find it difficult to
spend stuff on myself but this new puppy
like i don't care what it costs and
they're getting this imported swiss meat
or something like that for the dog i'm
like you could feed can't you just feed
a dog like what you know from costco or
something and she's like no
i said this is a great business so there
are a variety of different models i've
seen the box business which is amazing
um there's
decorative items for dogs which i love
because
the more
unnecessary they are
oftentimes the more profitable it can be
right i don't
you're not buying a luxury sweater
because you need it you're buying it
because you want it and price is largely
irrelevant so if i knew anything about
pets and had any interest whatsoever in
pets i would definitely start a pet
business i have a friend who sells dog
vitamins
and i asked him i go does it work he's
like i don't know
yeah yeah
i'm like that's the greatest this is the
greatest thing ever you have no i don't
knows
i should say that that idea and the next
idea i'm gonna share with you uh the
other thing i would have to have would
be no ethics whatsoever because half
these pet businesses are complete
horseshit um but you know
again i don't want to start it because i
don't know anything and i also do have
some morals around this but the pet
vitamins i mean come on what is the dog
giving you a report card oh i really
feel my uh scoliosis went away thanks to
this vitamin no
all right what's next um cosmetics
insatiable demand
uh
heavy rotation of using different types
of face clean do you guys know you may
not know as guys but do you know that
there's different lotions for your hands
feet
forehead are you aware of this sam no i
i i know
we have different uh lotions for
different skin color that's what we have
at our house so i know that but i didn't
know dude i haven't put lotion on in at
least 16 years like it's been it has
been 16 years since the last promotion
see this is revelatory for the audience
they're like what's lotion yeah there's
and by the way there's more to cosmetics
and skincare than lotion wait sean you
don't wear lotion i thought that dark
guys like you had to wear lotion never
wear lotion don't
choke your legs right now i want to see
if they have little cracks on them i'm
ashy and i'm proud of it look there's no
there's no workshop bro you gotta lotion
up come on dude
do you do sunscreen white guys use
sunscreen i don't use sunscreen
typically uh it'll also uh you know this
whole like
the whole like nighttime skincare
routine like you know i'm a toothbrush
and out of there it's it's over oh i
gotta tell you okay i gotta tell you my
favorite part about nighttime skin
routines this is my favorite thing on
all of social media so you'll be
following someone and someone will post
a question to them
uh oh my gosh your skin looks so good
what's your what's your skin care
routine and the person gets so excited
they go oh i'm so glad you asked me well
you know i like to really keep it simple
i'm just i'm all into simplicity so
here's what i do and then the 14 part
process
yeah they go well i start with a serum
then i give it a 15 minute break i put
on a lotion but then i put a cream on
top you know then i take a little break
and let it breathe then i use the brush
and then i ice it out and then and then
by lunch time you know i need to reapply
and then they have 13 other parts for
and i'm like do you understand that none
of that is simple most most of the
people i know are using like one proctor
and gamble product if that on their body
yeah three in one baby body shampoo
conditioner
yeah they're taking dove and putting it
on every part of their body and they're
like wow i really nailed it today
so um i would do a cosmetics or skin
care so these both people thought you
said pets and cosmetics those are i'm
with you
insatiable demand
like pricing sensitivity but
obviously competitive so how do you
think about going into a space that's
like you're not the first person to
think of cosmetics or pets so would you
be looking for if you were going to
approach this would you be looking for
some unique angle that you feel is
underserved or would you just say no
[__] i go i go swim
it doesn't matter how many other people
are fishing there there's enough fish
where i just want to make it i just want
to get my share i want a small slice of
a big pie what how would you approach it
packaging pricing and celebrities
packaging is a huge tremendous part of
it and i think there's some
opportunities there
pricing
what do you mean what opportunities
so i spoke to a guy who did a hair care
product and and i was like how did you
develop it he goes we basically went to
a factory and we were like uh whatever
it needs to fit this cost
uh
framework he didn't care so this is
again why i say i would not get into
this business if i had any morals which
i do that's why i'm not doing it but i'm
just telling you what he told me he goes
yeah i don't we don't care what it is it
needs to smell good
but we spend 90 of the time on the
packaging i go
what let me get this straight you're
basically selling
like [__] whatever
yeah and but the packaging looks lush
she goes
yeah that's what the entire business is
i go this is crazy
then this so in terms of price well how
big was that business or that
entrepreneur like how big was their
empire
i i imagine they had a bunch of them
yeah that's a good question i would say
in the
that's a good question if i had to guess
in the 30 to 50 million dollar range
by the last time i checked that was
several years ago
but you know i didn't ask so price
price is you know you see people doing
um
boxes
regular delivery
upsells there's lots of innovative
opportunities that i think digital
um entrepreneurs are very very smart at
in the old days it was put it on the
shelf at cvs and hope somebody buys it
and then comes back nowadays you can do
some really clever stuff so i think
that's an opportunity and then celebrity
tie-ins
who's known
for having amazing skin
and if you think back to those acne
commercials remember proactive they had
top tier celebrities so i got really
curious how do they get these a level
celebrities i started looking into it
the answer is they just write them a
humongous check
so there's opportunities with celebrity
tie-ins that for skin care again i am
not trying to do this business myself
i've just been fascinated with it and i
would love to see how someone would come
in here and disrupt what people are
normally doing
okay i like it and then did you have a
third one
kids anything on kids
i mean it's uh wow talk about price
insensitivity um
again i don't want to do this business
because i believe in less stuff for kids
i think there's more meaningful ways
um to parent but just imagine the kind
of
toys learning opportunities he's like
etcetera for children
could also talk he's like that's what a
kid is
[Laughter]
yeah uh
yeah
so you know there's some really smart
stuff around these areas but the key
denominator on all these is insatiable
demand that's the first place i look
which is a little ironic because when i
started i will teach you to be rich
there's actually not that much demand
for
learning about money especially when i
started it i focused on young people um
so i but i didn't it wasn't a business
when i started it was just like for fun
over time i found that there is demand
but you have to be very clever in how
you reach people
and what about uh money hacks so i i put
down a thing on the notes i said i want
to know
you have all this like corpus of content
you know just tons of tons of material
philosophies frameworks tactics
exercises blah blah blah
what would be the three
sort of money hacks that you think most
people just don't do but if you could
get them to do it you'd feel good about
it so what are your kind of like what
are your three
finance related or money related um
hacks that people should be doing that
gets you a big app big outcome with not
a huge input
well i'm glad you asked because most of
my founder friends don't even invest in
the market i would say over fifty
percent of that what what did you
understand no what does that even mean
that's so cra i that's so crazy to me i
don't understand it
well i'm about to tell you because these
guys make me want to ring their neck so
these are founders who have done very
well in their business either they have
a
high profit business generating
considerable amounts every year or
um to some extent they've had an exit
and now they're doing their next thing
i go hey what are you doing with your
money
they go oh you know i'm putting it into
my business i go cool like what about
investing they go no no no i can make
more money in the in my own business
this is where my voice starts to tighten
up and i bring out my hand as if i'm
about to ring their neck i go how many
businesses do you know that are still
around 50 years later and they go well
not many i go do you think it would be
good to maybe
take a little off the table and
put some in the market where you can get
really good returns
and it just boggles their mind because
they've never thought about they see
themselves as an entrepreneur
not a boring mom and pop investor that
is a very very costly belief that they
hold so i always tell them like hey take
a little bit put in the market boring
vanguard funds do the stuff of course
they haven't read my book do the stuff
in the book and when you do that you
will be wealthier than you can possibly
imagine and you your risk will be
decreased dramatically
um sean what do you think
so i follow a lot of what you say i've
read your book sarah my wife has read
your book you're going to talk about
like talking to your partner once a
month things like that i do that all but
i want to ask you sean
investing in the market so sean and i
are almost complete opposites when it
comes to money not complete opposites
for everything regarding money but our
risk profiles are very different
sean
do you invest just in normal index funds
at all
yeah i have some in index funds uh i
basically have a basket
of technology companies that a few years
ago i said okay what companies do i
think over a 10 to 20 year period just
have they have an advantage today that's
just going to compound for 10 to 20
years and i'm happy if i'm wrong with
that okay i'm wrong with that but i'm
going to have this basket of basically
six companies that i think
um
that i think are positioned to do that
and that was like amazon it was google
it wasn't like some i didn't take a
genius right it was just like i think
these companies essentially are
monopolies that uh that are riding this
wave of like the internet and mobile
phones they'll do well
and uh so i hold that so i'd say about
30 of my money is in that that selection
of stocks
i have probably
one percent
you can't import a camera
or the import tax on a camera that can
record above 60 minutes is taxed at a
video camera versus a picture camera
therefore you can't record for more than
60 minutes on a point-and-shoot camera
are you kidding me this is crazy well
sam much respect that was very now i
just need you to tell me what to do
about it but we can do that often yeah
that was impressive
yeah
so basically what happened to listeners
so it ramit's camera went off and this
is like a weird fact but uh point and
shoot cameras cannot record above 60
minutes because they would be taxed
differently it went down even better he
goes i know what happened uh we just hit
60 minutes didn't we yeah
and you have a uh a point shoot camera
don't you yeah it's from asia isn't it
yeah and it's like oh [__] sam i'm
saying what are you doing how do you do
all this
sam was like mike wallace right there
a lot of respect for you bro
yeah well all right we went through this
so sean you were saying that you have 30
percent in index funds where's the no
not even index
in a handful of tech stocks uh about six
tech stocks and then i have about
40-ish percent in crypto
i have a small amount maybe one percent
two percent still left in a vanguard
fund
and then uh what's left uh then i have
well i'm not counting just like
investments in private businesses like
startups and stuff that that would be
different but yeah the rest is like cash
and miscellaneous random other bets
is that crazy do you remember that
that's crazy to me i'm not disrespecting
you sean because whatever floats your
boat float your boat that's so different
from how i how i do stuff
it's like a guy going to a buffet okay
and you both go to a buffet and then you
go hey let's just let's meet up at the
table so you get here you get some rice
you get some chicken some vegetables and
the other guy comes back with three
different plates
90 of all the plates have chocolate cake
on them and then he has
two pieces of white fish
and uh
you know one piece of lobster that he
cut in half and he threw the threw it on
the floor you go what are you eating bro
he goes that's what i like
that's what
why because it's not vanguard it out
it's not indexed out is that why it's
not even remotely
of diversification now again if
if you want to be entertained that's
awesome it's very entertaining no i i
don't uh
i think diversification there's a great
great diversification is for losers uh
that's how i feel about diversification
that's how most tech uh founders feel
and the cost of their belief
is
vast it costs them typically millions
and millions of dollars they don't care
though this is my point sam it's it's
not they don't care
and i can angel invest i mean for me
some of the greatest investors the
greatest investors in the world do take
concentrated positions not diversified
positions so yeah
are you one of the greatest investors in
the world i know what i know in my
sphere i'm an expert in my field and so
i feel confident and comfortable
investing in my field i'm not saying i'm
one of the greatest investors in the
world but i know that
within the technology sector
i would bet on myself and that's what
i'm choosing to do right within the
technology sector i don't i feel like i
have an edge compared to uh what i can
get sort of in the passively diversified
index fund world
yeah right now your last 10 years i've
compounded way faster than you know the
vanguard etf or s sp500 generically has
your strategy for me i am the exact same
as you i'm looking at my portfolio now
it's basically 90 index funds or it
includes hubspot stock which is not
indexed but it's it's 90
publicly traded stock most of which is
is is is index funds but what bothers me
or me not bothers me it just shocks
boggles my mind about you how can you
not see that there is another way to do
it which are the crazy people like sean
when you and i both have tons of friends
that are these crazy people that have
made these ridiculous bets where they
only have 100 grand they put 90 grand
into crypto and it turns into 100
million dollars like you and i know many
of these people have done these stupid
things or they appear stupid and they
totally work out um well there's
definitely lots of different ways to
achieve it so you know when i talk about
my book there's there's lean fire
there's fat fire
there's
buying real estate there's passive
investing
and on and on so um
if you are optimizing for entertainment
great if you're optimizing for
concentrated risk
great then that portfolio makes a lot of
sense if you are optimizing for
a diversified low-cost predictable
return and mitigating risk then of
course that allocation makes exactly
zero sense so we want to know the game
that we are playing and sean you you
articulated it very well
what i think the next question that a
savvy investor would ask is
what are the risks that i am incurring
and this is typically where you get
people especially a lot of crypto bros
who go oh like what do i care i'm
swinging for the fences and you go okay
that's cool
what if it goes wrong now if you're 21
uh you know
your risk profile is low right worst
case you know you get a job et cetera et
cetera
if you're older if you have kids if you
have a mortgage or if you simply do not
want to go back to living on ramen
noodles then suddenly you start to think
about risk differently now here's the
catch
most people doesn't matter if they're 35
or 50 they don't truly understand risk
until something bad happens and when
that happens they do not take a look in
the mirror and go oh [__] my allocation
that i chose 15 years ago was poor they
go
[__] the government or they ripped me
off i need regulation even though i
called for no regulation for the last 15
years
so
unfortunately this is one of those
things that cannot be taught until it is
experienced and the market will go down
tech will not always go up this is a
predictable cycle the last 10 years have
been extraordinary there's no doubt
about that even an index investor made
over 15 annualized returns which is
insane
but
the music doesn't keep playing i agree
with you i i strongly disagree with
people uh
look like hold on hold on
it's there's no right answer without
saying what are you trying to do right
what is your goal because if my goal is
to make x and your goal is to make y
then we're going to have totally
different strategies like a different
strategy would work for a different
person what is your question i say i'm
comfortable with this much risk or i
have it i have knowledge about this
industry maybe my answer would be
different or maybe my strategy would be
different
um do you think our goals are different
yeah i think our goals are different for
sure what's your goal
not just not just the absolute money
goal right clearly our goals are
different because you you intentionally
avoid risk right like
you know the appeal of a lot of these
investments so you don't want to lose
right you your risk tolerance is lower
and you are you are you would feel worse
if you lost then you would feel good if
you win and i'm the opposite i would
feel worse if i didn't follow my
convictions than if i but what's your
goal like is there a point where you'll
say i'm gonna i'm gonna i don't want to
take more risk
yeah of course over time it'll shift
right as the as the principal gets large
enough then you don't need to have so
much concentration because you can have
more you can play play it safer and you
can take a smaller a lower return will
still yield
it will still let you live a lifestyle
that you want but if the principal's
small and you're trying to live off four
percent gains or five percent gains or
seven percent annual gains
um you're gonna have to sit there for 40
years and like i'm just not interested
in doing that and i think another thing
is like what's your other situation is
like how much income do you bring out i
bring in a lot of income so i'm not
really worried about
okay what happens if the market goes
down either temporarily or even
permanently it's like if i'm bringing in
a healthy income and i'm young
i don't really have to worry too much
about protecting this investment asset
first i can play riskier than my dad who
no longer can generate significant
income and he needs to play it safer
i think yeah we have different we have
different
we have different goals
yeah i think um if you if you look at
bodybuilders for example who are
competitive
eventually all roads lead to chicken and
rice
all roads lead to chicken and rice why
because when you look at macronutrients
and when you look at where you're
getting the highest bang for your buck
all professional bodybuilders
essentially eat the same okay i'm being
a little general here but that's the
case
when you look at investing if you look
at the research and yes you clarify your
goals but um
remember that in investing a lot of
people go personal finance is personal
actually most people are mostly the same
let me say that again most people are
mostly the same they mostly want to make
good money be able to travel a little
bit etc so unless you are
a wild outlier
then all roads lead to
low-cost long-term investing again there
are outliers
sean it sounds like you've thought that
through
but
the principles of chicken and rice and
low-cost investing are the same now what
are those principles i talked about that
in chapter six you know there's a lot of
people tossing around these things about
well you know i chose this because like
the market went down a little bit so i
put my money in here and like over time
all those timing the market things have
been blown out there are the rare
exceptions who win
uh sam you were referring to that you
know we know some people who have won
yeah you know we also know a lot of
people who lost a lot of money and they
disappear they don't brag about their
russian fund that they picked anymore
that's called survivorship bias so it's
important that we know the entire game
of play and then we choose otherwise
it's very emotionally tempting to be
like i'm a genius i have an edge etc but
we have to all remember we are
individual investors and even the pros
who do this for a living with a bunch of
other smart people and expensive
technology
they fail to beat the market 80 plus
percent of the time
what are your money rules you talk about
you need to have money rules what are
yours
uh i have 10 money rules i'll share
some of them so the easy ones are things
like always have a year of emergency
uh fund cash okay that's sort of a
simple one
invest 20 of gross income minimum that's
an easy one if you can't do twenty
percent
do start with five percent right but the
the important thing is pick a number and
automate it that's critical
then the lar the the different ones for
me my money rules are things like um
never question
spending on books
appetizers health or a friend's charity
fundraiser so that's unlimited i have
unlimited spend on that and why like why
am i talking about appetizers
it's meaningful to me when i was a kid
we couldn't afford to eat appetizers now
when i go out and eat with a friend i'm
like whatever looks good just order it
right we can we can get everything here
and then it gets a little bigger you
know business class on flights over four
hours that's a rule i don't have to
debate it or think about it it's just
boom it's done
and be able to pay in full
for large expenses like a wedding a
honeymoon even a house
doesn't mean i have to pay in full i
could finance it if the interest is low
or whatever
but for the largest most important
purchases in my life i don't want cost
to be a factor
now if you're listening to this some of
these sound totally bewildering maybe
even ridiculous okay
uh that's the point
my money rules are mine they are not
applicable to most people most people
don't care about appetizers and most
people can't buy a house all cash that's
okay what i want to encourage you to do
is to really write down your money rules
instead of having to make a thousand
decisions every month about money boil
it up roll it up to the things that are
meaningful
and you'll notice on my money rules
which you can just google ramit's money
rules
that the classic mistake people make i
say hey what are your money rules and
they're all restrictive never spend on
premium this never do that never done
enough i go okay okay it's okay to have
a couple restrictive rules you know you
want to save you want to invest
but let's also make some rules that are
fun money is supposed to be fun it's not
about cutting back on lattes it's about
living a rich life sam do you have those
yeah i have those written down or just
kind of like intuited like you know i
kind of live by these or have you like
actually sat down and said these are
mine
well so when i um
was 25
i made a list maybe i was 22. i made a
list i said here's how much money i want
to have by the age of 30. here's how
much i want to spend each month here's
what i want to purchase like the
spending that i the budget that i made
each month was based off of what i
wanted to own and what i wanted to do
and so i had this i had similar rules
written down where it was basically
uh
anything health related i in book and
books um i don't look at the i don't
look at the price i just buy whatever i
want
um i did not have any rules towards
charity although that's changing i do i
need to get into that um
but yeah i had like i worked backwards i
had like a target number based off of
one i wanted to spend each month and i
wanted to be able to um
hit that tar i wanted to be able to make
that just off of uh
my gains like my my passive income from
index fund investing uh and i wanted to
be able to withdraw only three percent
of that per year in order to pay for my
monthly expenses and i and i made that
all up when i was like 22 23 24. i
forget the exact number but by the way
when people say that oh i want to
withdraw four percent do they actually
withdraw do you actually like me do you
actually sell down four percent of your
uh whatever your your index funds are or
whatever to pay for your lifestyle or do
is that just a theoretical thing like i
can
i could fund this off just the gains you
know just a portion of the of the of the
annual gains
well i don't use a drawdown i'm not in
the de-accumulation phase so i have an
income but eventually one day
yeah and in fact do people do that yeah
every retiree does that de-accumulation
is done by tens of millions of people
they sell off a little bit every single
year if they've got it and that's how
they fund themselves that's why it's
called a fixed income
and there's but but there's other
there's
there's other ways you could do it so
for example i just invested into this
real estate fund um
what's the it's a big it's a big one
called oak tree or something uh and then
blackrock or what's it blackstone what's
the big the big the big you know the big
guy it's like the
it's like the trillion dollar real
estate thing everyone has access to it
and anyway it pays i think a
six and a half to seven percent dividend
quarterly and you can live off that um
if you put you know a fair bit yeah
sean's a good question there are other
ways too so dividends are one another
thing that really wealthy investors will
do is they'll simply take loans against
their yes that's that's kind of what i
was talking about was like talk about
that for a minute because you're not
paying tax on the like you sell your
[__] or you take a dividend you're gonna
pay tax so you're six percent is not six
percent but correct if you you know if
you live off your loans you keep your
assets compounding that seems smarter to
me the the blown thing is the craziest
thing that i've i've just recently
learned about this it is it's taken me
so long to grasp this because it goes
against everything that i thought was
true
so basically it's illegal
it feels illegal so basically when you
get to like i don't know what the number
is there's some number where you can
start borrowing money from big banks
right now i think what's the rate like
my rate is one point one percent one
percent yeah
it's crazy okay and so the the bankers
was like yeah look like and i like built
a widget so i could like look at it so
let's just i'm just going to use a bunch
of made up numbers so let's just say
that you have uh 10 million dollars in a
equity fund okay you could borrow i
believe if you have index fund up to 70
of that so you can borrow seven million
dollars
and there's the the way the math works
and it's different for each person based
off of the stocks that you own but
basically you can withdraw let's say 30
percent in the uh 30 of your 7 million
and the market would have to drop by
like 68 70 percent in order for you to
even have to pay back anything otherwise
you could basically have that
outstanding forever and it's only
extruding interest at a one percent rate
and you could use that money to live off
of or you can use that money to invest
in other stuff it's astounding to me am
i am i remember you have a smirk on your
face am i am i getting this wrong
well i have a i was born with a smirk on
my face so let's just
i'm smiling inside but
i just look like this so you in general
you are right in general you are right
it is almost unbelievable the average
investor does not have
um
the ability to do this they have access
to it they just don't have enough money
for it but i do want to point one thing
out
a lot of these seemingly
too good to be true things have
sprung up and become popularized in the
last 10 years
is there anything else that might have
been going on in the financial markets
for the last decade maybe that would
have enabled these things to become
popular such as a record-breaking bull
market and historical low
interest rates yes so you we need to put
this in context of history yeah you can
borrow at one percent
rate but if go talk to your parents ask
them what their mortgage rate was when
they bought a house in the 80s yeah but
these
but these rates are based what's it
called the london what's it called the
libor i forget what libor stands for but
dude i believe i went and i think the i
think libor has only been around since
the 50s but since the 50s i think the
highest has ever been is three and a
half percent
i that's interesting i have to look at
that i'm not sure about that
is it fixed or variable
it's variable so that's why it's
dangerous
yeah yes that's my point sam let's talk
about the danger so again i don't know
if it has to drop by 68
the banks can call in their loan once it
breaks a threshold so all of this is
amazing
until it's not and so you i don't mean
to be the sort of luddite here or the
the boring voice and this is
unfortunately what sensible investors
get thrust into when there's an insane
bull market you have guys like me coming
and saying hey it's cool you want to put
5-10 percent of your money in some
alternative investment awesome but
remember this doesn't always last
forever i've seen it myself three times
in my life and i'm not even 40 years old
i've seen in the 2000 crash 2008
and yeah you could say march 2020 that
was temporary
but people are real tough until things
go wrong and suddenly you see people
lose fortunes when i went to omaha to
see warren buffett at his conference one
of the things that he and charlie munger
said was
we set up berkshire so we can never run
out of money
and to me
that is way more inspirational than
i eked out an extra 1.5 return at a much
higher risk rate so i want everybody to
know the game they're playing do you
want to get uh
10 or 14 compounded annualized uh return
rates you can it's possible you'll take
on a massive amount of risk and when you
you think about it it reminds me of what
my trainer said right we were starting
to lift heavier and heavier and i was
like oh so like how heavy should we go
and he goes you know at a certain point
you really want to ask yourself do you
need to put on that extra plate if
you're competing maybe
but there's a risk that you're suddenly
taking and we need to not just think
about returns 14 we need to think about
what can go wrong as well and for a lot
of people they have never done what you
did sam they never sat out and plotted
out how much money they don't even know
what they want to do with their money
and so i want people to think a little
more deeply this is one of the most
important things in your life and for
most people you will find that if they
get a nice simple eight percent
annualized return rate over time and
they continue contributing they actually
have more money than they know what to
do with
it takes time yes
but i i want to challenge people to
really think about this sensible
yeah i think one of the good things
about what you do but also one of the
disconnects between what we talk about
is
um
your message to help a mass number of
people as you have is a most people
message what i call a most real message
you're trying to find the advice that
you can give that if most people took it
would actually help them out and
they may not have an outlier in either
direction negative or extreme positive
and so you have most people advice our
podcast
our broadcast is the exact opposite our
target audience is for people who are
trying to escape most people results
they are trying to have a sort of out
how do you have a disproportionately
outsized positive result whether it's
because you built a schedule i think
that's a good clarification i will say
i think you earn the right
to have
an outlier result
it is you hear stories about oh let's do
this startup and we'll make 10 million
dollars or 50 million great those are
extremely rare
and um
instead my approach is layer it so as i
talk about and i will teach bridge it's
not just about personal finance about a
rich life start off get your diversified
portfolio never worry about that again
right i spend less than one hour per
month on my finances then you want more
start a business right make a huge
profitable business or if you want to do
a venture back business great
but you earn the right to be an outlier
it is extremely rare and very unlikely
that someone's just like oh i have this
cool idea for a dog business i'm gonna
make 50 million bucks that's my personal
philosophy right and i think the the
bodybuilder analogy you said earlier is
correct but it's actually a different
point of what you're making which is
most people don't want to be
bodybuilders bodybuilder diet is
actually chicken rice and hgh right and
and there's going to be a lot of a lot
of downsides to the amount of you know
stuff they're shooting into their body
but they need to do it because that is
that game that is a specific game same
thing with venture back startups venture
back startups is not just even business
it's the olympics of business right it's
basically saying billion dollars a bus
that's what you're signing up for that's
why it's really easy to
to [__] on it or call out fairly that
hey
don't get caught up in the hype there
are many other ways to win that are
often like easier
more pleasurable and whatnot
but like that is the olympics and that's
why it gets celebrated right we
celebrate michael phelps even though it
took immense sacrifice for him to go
earn those eight medals like you know he
swam you know
six hours a day and eight twenty
thousand calories a day because that's
what it took to compete at that level
and so i think it's important for people
to figure out what is the what is the
advice they want to take like um
i always say this thing i say i don't
most people don't have good results uh
which is basically you know most
marriages and divorce most people are
are overweight most
if you just follow what most people do
you will get the results that most
people are getting right now which is
not very not really lined up with what
people want which is to be you know fit
happy and successful and um
and so you have to kind of figure that
out and i would say we're pretty aligned
on that i think what you what you offer
is a path that will work for almost
anybody and what we sometimes talk about
is a path that won't work for most
people but for the few people who it
will work for it'll work in a big way
and so it's like two kind of different
two different ends of the same thing
yeah i think that's an interesting
approach uh a different interesting
distinction to make between the two
approaches sam what do you think you've
been in both worlds
yeah i
so
i kind of do this thing where i put
i like to have
i like to have i don't even know what i
call it but basically if everything goes
to [__] i'm okay
so i i like to have this base of
security this this this fortress of [__]
you
and uh i like to have that and then
anything above that i go incredibly
balls to the wall totally risky with sam
we're the same i have what i call the
tripod of stability right where i where
i work or sorry where i live
uh these sort of basic fundamentals
health relationships that's all dialed
in it's relatively
conservative but then it allows me to be
risk seeking on certain things like oh
let me try this random podcast with no
business model whatsoever or let me try
this experimental program
uh et cetera et cetera so i like that
but again
we need to know who what game we're
playing and who we are right all things
you know what does mike tyson say
everybody's got to play until they get
punched in the face everyone's an
investment champ until the market goes
down and
in order to see evidence of this all you
need to do is go to any investment forum
including fat fire lean fire any fire
even the boba heads for them and cycle
back to what happened in 2008 cycle back
to what happened in march 2020 and you
will or my favorite is go to the crypto
subreddits and you'll see people
all the bravado fades away and they go
oh my god i just lost my kids college
fund you do not want to be in that
position ever on the other hand you can
make a lot of money if you have a
sensible investment or even a risk
seeking investment so but i think
i think
wow
i think what you and i slightly differ
go different paths for me is well i
don't know if it's entirely true but
basically i see i have i've got so many
friends that like if i told you what
they do well you you're in the world so
you know but if i told my parents what
they do they'd be like this is [__]
nuts
and and and they would be like what are
you talking about like
sean is like that a lot of me and sean's
friends the guy sean used to work for
michael birch was like that like you are
[__] crazy this is nutty this is not
gonna work i have so many friends who
they have made it work and i and i
understand that in order to have
outsized results you have to do some
wacky ass [__] sometimes and i accept
that you have to you have to be weird
i accept also that i'm not like that the
other thing i'll point out is it is not
always true that to get more reward you
take more risk there are moments in time
and
a wise good investor eventually
identifies these and it takes time to
develop this judgment there are times
where you can take low risk bets that
have disproportionate rewards and
they're not often and it's easy to talk
yourself into thinking that everything
is like that but uh
but
you know sometimes there's this myth
that oh if you want rewards you have to
take massive proportional risk and it's
not always proportional and uh and those
are actually the best opportunities
those are the those are the ones that
you should be like pouncing on and maybe
to others it looks like you're doing
something crazy but if you have
accurately assessed it you may find that
it was actually not as high risk but
still high reward the way you do stuff
sean i think it's just like
the way that i view it it's like i think
it's crazy and but i accept that your
returns might be massive
yeah
that's a good way to put it i mean
everybody's playing their game right but
you but to assess it you need to assess
it over the correct period of time and
with the correct goals in mind sam you
might be like ah you know let's fast
forward maybe
two kids
not gonna do that
sean might say i don't care or i put
some money in the bank etc there's a
whole bunch of ways to evaluate it but i
i appreciate that sean there definitely
different perspectives and i appreciate
hearing you know what game you are
optimizing for i think that that makes
sense yeah and what i would encourage
anyone to do is i would actually start
with your stuff and learn
learn the fundamentals it's like okay i
yeah i sometimes do some street [__]
but like you know
you can only do that once you first
understand the fundamentals you do them
for a while and then you start to
identify okay where do i want to if i am
going to stray from the pack right if i
am going to not play by the book i
better have a really strong reason to do
so i'm going to have some like some real
conviction a real knowledge a real point
of view that i am willing and i'm i'm i
actually understand what the heck i'm
doing and i understand that the the the
risks that i am taking with when i take
those risks right so you want to start
there not start with oh i saw this dude
on reddit did this thing and uh so i'm
gonna go yolo that same trade and i
don't even know what the hell i'm
actually doing yeah whatever you see on
reddit you should immediately close that
window and never listen to any financial
advice on that [__] site listen you
need to be able to answer some basic
questions if you want to do all this
risk seeking stuff you know
um what is diversification mean what is
the typical asset allocation for a 40
year old and why where does this 8
return per year come from where's what
is that what's the rule of 72
when is my debt going to be paid off um
what do i actually want to do with my
money if i have 500k a million 5 million
if you can't answer these questions you
are not ready to begin taking all this
uh astronomical risk again none of this
matters because none of these people are
listening to me right now they shut this
off two hours ago they're like [__] this
old guy
risk see i'm a risk seeker he's so whole
no you will time will tell but i would
strongly encourage you to be able to
answer some of these basic questions
before you choose your own path and many
times what i find is people start off
they're really gung-ho they get into
this they're like oh [__] this is
actually really easy i spend less than
an hour a month my money's growing like
crazy i don't have to worry about it
ever again we're going to be
multi-millionaires let me go live my
life that's way more exciting than
optimizing some [__] 0.5
return
sam you know i've been telling you about
this too that's why i told you stop
talking about your 3
drawdowns like that's all great when
you're 21 and it's cool now let's talk
about where are you going on vacation
that is way more interesting you told me
where to go i booked my tickets i had my
european trip planned it got canceled
because of delta but i do what you say
by the way let me share your side of the
story on the engagement ring you gave
sam some advice on the engagement ring
okay so
you know sam uh
sam is a very good listener sam i have
to say i appreciate you you you ask for
advice which is rare and you listen so
i'm always like yeah let's talk so he
comes he he's telling you about you know
he's gonna propose and you know i i got
married three years ago so i went
through the whole process and
i got very deep into
um the whole wedding thing and all that
stuff and people like oh was was your
wife like a um bridezilla i was like if
anyone was going to be a zilla it was
going to be this groom zilla right here
because i knew like all that i was
loving
so
just a couple
contexts
part of my philosophy is
save for the big things before you need
them because you know that they're going
to happen most people are going to be
married so i started saving putting
money away from my wedding uh and my
honeymoon like in my 20s before i even
met my wife
why because i knew it was going to
happen one day and i wanted to have an
awesome wedding a awesome ring awesome
honeymoon
again my own philosophy for you
important things in life i don't want to
have to look at the price okay so a lot
of people like that's crazy why would i
start saving when i'm not even in a
relationship that's weird i go what's
weird
is to get to your
wedding planning and not have enough
money or
um you know basically just have to make
all these short-term decisions some
people go into debt for their wedding i
don't believe in it i want you to have
an amazing extravagant wedding if that's
what you want or a beautiful honeymoon
or whatever
i i want you to be start planning early
so sam comes to me he goes
hey i'm thinking of getting this uh
thing i said oh cool you know how are
you thinking about it and he tells me
yeah i have this like budget in mind so
i said
yeah thank you i was like you i was like
no you're gonna spend more than that
now why did i say that to him
because i know how much money he has
okay and i know that there are certain
benchmarks and certain numbers
that if he had if he was a school
teacher and he told me five grand i
would say oh my god that's amazing like
she's gonna love it
and then i went a little deeper because
sam got very quiet sam knew he was being
cheap but he didn't know how to
articulate he had a lot of emotions
running through his body i said sam let
me ask you a couple questions because he
started off with this utilitarian
silicon valley
he goes oh you know what all you guys
already know the argument oh i don't
believe in diamonds it's all made up
it's so fake well why don't we just get
this [__] you know and i'm like okay
sam let me ask you a question um does
your fiance care about rings no no no no
she's not that kind of person i said oh
okay okay hey out of curiosity
does she have a pinterest board he goes
oh yeah i go what's on that pinterest
board relating to rings oh she's been
like tracking rings for like the last 15
years and goes damn
have you talked to her about this he
goes well she did mention that she kind
of wants like and then he breaks down
like the entire thing of what kind of
ring she wants
you can afford it this is important to
her this is not about you and your dumb
vision as a 21 year old utilitarian it's
about what your future wife for the rest
of your life wants this one thing and
sam was awesome sam you listened you
were like oh like he never thought about
it like that because it's all tech bros
into someone who actually you know is
like let's talk about the softer side
and it was awesome sam take it from
there what happened when you went to get
that ring
i'll yeah i'll say i i i i was going to
spend five grand i was like i i i can't
do this anymore and i ended up i think i
spent a lot 28 29 30 000
but it's not about the money sam it's
not about the money what why don't you
matter bro do you want the details of
the story people want to know
you're right right they want the details
of the story i've given the details of
the story and
looking back the money it didn't matter
at all and she was incredibly happy and
i felt so proud
dude
my man so i'm i'm happy for you i'm
happy for your wife i i actually i'm
glad you mentioned the numbers and you
guys are awesome on this podcast you're
always mentioning numbers which is very
rare so i love it
but what i want to emphasize is that at
a certain point it's actually not about
the dollar value and people particularly
entrepreneurs and particularly tech guys
are obsessed with monetization they're
always talking about numbers yeah you
should know your numbers yes but their a
rich life is so much more than your
numbers just think about this when you
went home to visit your parents and you
hugged your mom or your dad did you
think about oh how much is this costing
me in my hourly rate oh how much did my
mom pay for that chicken because we
could get it cheaper at costco no
the most important thing in life are
actually not quantifiable so what i want
to emphasize is that
we are we're taught from day one and i
started a silicon valley tech company we
raised money i've done all this stuff so
i know what i'm talking about
we are taught that quantifying is the
most important thing you do what are
your metrics what's your attribution
what's your conversion rate that's all
we talk about and yet in the most
important things in life sitting outside
on a picnic with our kids
going being able to extend your lunch on
a weekday with your friend from college
who just happens to be in
money is irrelevant the number is
irrelevant being able to do it is rich
and so for sam
sam i [__] love it
you did it the money part
irrelevant you had the money you could
do it more important was recognizing my
wife wants this it's important to her
and i'm gonna rewrite my old story from
when i was 21 into a new man and a new
partner and i'm going to use some of my
resources to do it and that that is
connective and amazing
well thank you and and we'll have to end
with that beautiful uh that beautiful
little monologue there you're the man
what's the name of the podcast again
i will teach you to be rich with ramit
sethi
and uh i'm looking it up now we're gonna
link to it um thanks dude this is
awesome but you have a a link that you
go to too right
yeah you can go to iwt.com podcast or
it's on apple or spotify
well thanks man this is awesome what do
you say sean yeah thanks for coming on
sam i think you and sarah should go on
his pod and be one of the couples
i'm down i'm down
that would make me uncomfortable but i
would do it
[Music]
let's travel never looking back